The answer is negative seven.
There's a lot going on here, so
let's take this step-by-step.
The first thing we need to do
is look at the grouping symbols.
Here we have nesting grouping symbols
with parentheses inside brackets.
When this is the case, do the innermost
set of grouping symbols first and
then work your way out.
So the first thing we should
do is six minus eight.
Six minus eight equals negative two.
So we'll just rewrite our expression and
substitute in negative two and
this is our new expression.
Now let's work our way out four
minus negative 2 equals 6.
We'll rewrite our expression again and
substituting six in for four minus
negative two, our expression becomes six
divided by six plus negative two cubed.
When parentheses are used
to indicate clarity, for
example, keeping a sign
associated with a number,
we don't treat them as grouping
symbols like we normally would.
The next thing that we need to
do is evaluate this exponent.
We're not evaluating this next
because of the parentheses but
because it's an exponent.
So negative two with parenthesis
cubed is equal to negative two
times negative two minus two
which is equal to negative eight.
So our new expression becomes six
divided by six plus negative eight.
Now we've done all the grouping
symbols and all the exponents.
Next thing to do is multiply and
divide from left to right.
Six divided by six equals one.
We substitute that back into our
original equation to get one plus
negative eight.
One plus negative eight equals
negative seven, and we're all set.